-It's time for "Tonight Show
Stocking Stuffers"!
Here we go!
-♪ "Tonight Show" ♪
-♪ Stocking Stuffers ♪
-♪ It's the "Tonight Show" ♪
-Every night until
Christmas break,
we're giving away an
incredible gift
to every single person
in our studio audience.
Are you guys ready for this?
Ready to see
what you're taking home?
Questlove, drumroll, please.
[ Drumroll ]
Tonight's stocking stuffer is a
House of Marley Get Together 2
mini wireless Bluetooth speaker!
[ Cheers and applause ]
Yes, Jimmy,
created in collaboration with
the Marley family, the
House of Marley Get Together 2
mini wireless
dust- and water-proof speaker
is crafted with natural bamboo
and REWIND fabric created from
99% post-consumer materials.
The speakers boast 15 hours of
perfectly balanced sound,
making it excellent
for any adventure.
Head to houseofmarley.com
to get yours!
Jimmy?
-Thank you very much, Higgins.
Look at this.
Look at the woofer on this.
Look at the bass on this guy.
Ooh!
[ Imitates bass thumping ]
Yeah.
How about we test
these guys out?
[ Cheers and applause ]
You guys want to hear
how they sound?
Here we go. Let's go.
-♪ There are times
when I look above and beyond ♪
♪ There are times when I
feel your arms around me, baby ♪
[ Crowd cheering ]
-[ Laughs ]
-What -- what is going on?!
Janet Jackson!
-Jimmy...
-Janet Jackson is in the house!
[ Cheers and applause ]
-I see you on this.
What are you doing?
-Janet, what are you doing here?
What are you --
-Listen, I start my new tour,
"Together Again," in April,
and I was looking for someone
to come onstage
and dance with me
at Madison Square Garden.
-And you --
So, you saw my dance moves
and you, like,
want me to go on tour?
This right there?
I'm a little stiff, but, yeah.
You're looking for dancers?
-Yes.
-You're looking for --
-No, that ain't gonna
make it, Jimmy.
-I'm not going to make it.
Thank you very much.
I appreciate it. I was trying --
-No, but, listen, I would love
to see if someone
from the audience wants to try.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Yeah?
-Does someone want to dance
with Janet Jackson?
You, sir,
in the hat right there.
Why don't you pick one,
and I'll pick one.
You -- How about that guy
with the hat?
-Okay.
-I think he should come down.
Yeah, I think so.
♪♪
And who else?
-The girl with the black shirt.
-In the black shirt, yes.
Come on down.
-Whoo!
-Welcome. Hi.
Hello. What is your name?
-Jenny Mariani! Hi!
-Hi! Where are you --
-Whoo-hoo!
[ Cheers and applause ]
-What is your name?
-Jeff. Jeff Cherry.
Jenny looks like a real dancer.
-She does?
-Thank you.
-No, I think you look like
a real dancer, too.
I mean, come on.
I can see some moves here.
Alright, now, Janet,
do they need to know anything
before they dance for you?
-No, no. Just freestyle.
Just do what you want to do.
Just --
No, seriously, freestyle.
-Here we go. This is freestyle.
Let's play a little
"Together Again"
for them right now.
-♪ There are times
when I look above and beyond ♪
♪ There are times when I
feel your arms around me, baby ♪
-No, hey, that's not bad.
I mean...
And a spin.
A lot of spins
going around there, too.
-Come on.
-I can do that spin.
Alright, I like that.
Alright, I think that's good.
Janet, what do you think?
Do they have what it takes?
-You know what?
I would love for
both of you guys
to come and
dance with me onstage, yeah?
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪
As a matter of fact,
I would love to give
tickets to everybody here
in the audience
for the
Madison Square Garden show.
-Oh, my God! Come on, now!
[ Cheers and applause ]
That's what I'm talking about!
You're all getting tickets to
see Janet Jackson
on her "Together Again" tour
at Madison Square Garden!
What a night this is!
Janet Jackson, everybody!
You can get presale tickets to
her "Together Again" tour
right now.
Tickets officially
go on sale tomorrow.
We'll be right back with more of
"The Tonight Show"!
-What was that?
♪♪